hey guys it's evan i'm in my billiards
room here and i suck at billiards for
the record but i wanted to have some fun
so created these guides that will help
you with your business worksheets and
kind of guide you through step-by-step
how to build your business and i want to
give a few of them away for free and
here's the game okay what I'm going to
do is I'm going to line up the balls on
the table here and I want you guys to
comment below so here's a picture of the
balls let me load it up here so you guys
can see okay I'm going to come back I'm
going to fill a video of me trying to
sink one of these balls from the break
and hopefully I can get one in and what
I want you to do is put your name down
with each color so pick a color pic
which ball you think I'm going to sing
first and if you win i'm going to give
you the free entire collection of the
guides okay it's a 97 dollar value you
get it for free to help build your
business i'm gonna have some fun in the
process if I sink more than one then
every ball that I think if you picked it
you get it so what I want you to do with
in the comments just let me know which
ball is yours and whoever is the first
one that claimed that ball if I sink it
you get the prize so we've got let's go
in order here just so we have clarity
we've got orange striped tie what is
that maroon striped blue green red
striped purple striped red yellow stripe
yellow purple white I hope it'll sink
the white one orange black blue striped
green stripe and maroon okay those are
options leave it in the comments below
and whichever one I say you guys get the
full guide set and hopefully I don't
embarrass myself with my my pool skills
so we'll see all right leave a comment
we'll have some fun and see what happens
you